sie ist für tausende das Tor nach Europa
fucks Küstenstadt in Tunesien Migranten
die meisten von ihnen aus Westafrika
verdienen sich am Rande der Medina ein
pardiner für einen Platz auf einem Boot
in einer der Seiten Straßen sind wir mit
cindu und bubakar verabredet weil die
beiden Angst vor der Polizei haben
drehen wir unauffällig mit dem Handy sie
erzählen uns von ihren Fluchtversuchen
wir sind immer in Kontakt fragen wie
viel Geld hast du was kannst Du dazu
geben und dann bezahlen ein paar von uns
das Buch andere kaufen Benzin
und wenn sie mich tausendmal zur
umkehrzwingen ich versuche es wieder
sobald ich das Geld habe
umgerechnet gut 1000 € müssen sie
auftreiben inzwischen organisieren sie
die Boote für ihre Überfahrten selbst
denn sie misstrauen den schmuggern
vermuten dass die mit den tunesischen
Behörden zusammenarbeiten
die Küstenwache kann uns mit aller Kraft
aufhalten und uns zwingen zurückzufahren
oder aber sie stoppen uns und nehmen uns
das Benzin weg oder den Motor und dann
lassen Sie uns auf dem Wasser treiben
diese Bilder hat eine Nachricht in
Agentur gedreht die Einsatzleitung der
Küstenwache streitet die Vorwürfe ab es
gäbe dafür keine Belege nach Angaben von
Frontex sind seit Jahresbeginn etwa
40.000 Migranten über das Mittelmeer
nach Europa gekommen
um die Menschen auf sie zu stoppen wird
die Küstenwache finanziell und technisch
auch von der EU unterstützt eine
Zusammenarbeit die bei
Menschenrechtsorganisationen in der
Kritik steht
allein in den vergangenen Monaten
ertranken hunderte Migranten rund ums
Fax werden immer mehr Leichen aus dem
Meer geborgen Naila die für das
städtische Krankenhaus arbeitet
beschreibt mit nüchternen Zahlen die
große
Halle können wir 35 Personen aufnehmen
gerade sind dort mehr als 170
[Musik]
aus hygienischen Gründen weigere sich
das Personal inzwischen dort
hineinzugehen die Ärztin wie ihre
Kollegin bedrückt die Situation weit
über das medizinische hinaus
man muss endlich eine dauerhafte Antwort
auf das Flüchtlingsproblem finden nicht
nur kurzfristig agieren die Situation
beruhigt sich dann zwar vorübergehend
aber es geht immer wieder von vorne los
zumal der Druck steigt soziale und
wirtschaftliche Krisen sowie zunehmender
Rassismus treiben die Menschen aus dem
Land und franceigi fühlt sich ohnmächtig
der Kameruner lebt seit fünf Jahren in
Tunesien er berät mit seinem Verein
junge Migranten gemeinsam suchen sie
nach Alternativen zur Flucht nach Jobs
einem legalen Weg doch das werde immer
schwerer seitdem der Präsident in einem
mittlerweile gelöschten Social Media
Beitrag gegen Horden illegaler Migranten
hetzte die das Verbrechen ins Land
bringen würden
[Musik]
die Kommunikation nach diesem reden im
Februar und März kam es zu Gewalt und
Verletzungen
die Menschen haben ihre Arbeit verloren
sie wurden aus ihren Wohnungen
rausgeworfen und es blieb ihnen nichts
anderes übrig als völlig unvorbereitet
über das Meer zu fliehen
wie er ist auch nur ausgebildeter
Ingenieur wollte ebenfalls gerne in
Tunesien bleiben sein Studentenvisum mit
dem er eingereist ist ist abgelaufen
neue Papiere zu bekommen kompliziert
bist unmöglich er weiß nicht wohin und
wie er durch den Alltag kommen soll
ich zahle für bestimmte Produkte auf dem
Markt höhere Preise als die tunesia
und ich muss auch mehr Miete für meine
Wohnung zeigen
die Einwanderer werden für sämtliche
Probleme Tunesiens zum Sündenbock
gemacht
Arbeitslosigkeit Armut das Land ist
hochverschuldet und Kreditverhandlungen
mit dem Internationalen Währungsfonds
stocken weil Tunesiens autokratischer
Präsident Reformen ablehnt stattdessen
schürt er mit Verschwörungstheorien das
Misstrauen in der Bevölkerung abends an
der Promenade von Fax hören wir seine
ausländerfeindlichen Parolen ungefiltert
sie greifen uns an stehlen überfallen
uns sie sind zu nichts zu gebrauchen
diese Afrikaner
[Musik]
ich fände es gut wenn der Staat sie
einfach wegschickt für uns hier bleibt
doch nichts mehr übrig am besten wäre
sie gehen direkt nach Italien ohne
vorher nach Tunesien zu kommen
einfach nur weg das wollen viele
Migranten nun die italienische Insel
Lampedusa liegt keine 200 Kilometer von
hier entfernt wir treffen Buba Karin
noch einmal er hat uma dabei sie halten
an ihrem Traum von einem besseren Leben
in Europa fest
mein Vater meine Brüder meine Schwester
zu Hause zählen alle auf mich ich kann
nicht so einfach zurück ich möchte
meiner Familie aus dem Elend raushelfen
[Musik]
ins Glück
aber es macht mich auch nachdenklich
wenn ich aufs Meer schaue habe ich viele
Bilder im Kopf
ich denke an all die die ich kannte und
die dort im Meer geblieben sind
[Musik]
und doch wollen sie los sobald es geht
warten auf den Moment an dem sie in ein
Boot steigen und Tunesien endlich
verlassen können
[Musik]